all right let's start today by going
through a few things about this week
that I didn't have time for earlier in
the week there's this guy named Charlie
Kirk he's part of the right wing group
Turning Point USA and he had a really
bad day on Tuesday Not only was Donald
Trump indicted but we saw Brendan
Johnson win the Mayoral race in Chicago
we also saw this liberal Supreme Court
Wisconsin Supreme Court candidate win
her race in Wisconsin making Wisconsin
now have a left-leaning supreme court
for the first time in 15 years and
Charlie Kirk recognizes that result
decreases their chances of being able to
win the White House in 24. he won't say
why but obviously it's because they plan
to cheat they plan to go to the Supreme
Court of Wisconsin to try to get the
Wisconsin electoral votes in 2024
whether or not their candidate gets the
most votes take a listen to this
yesterday was not a good day
Not only was Trump arraigned Wisconsin
was a blowout and there goes the
Wisconsin Supreme Court and it decreases
our chance to be able to win the White
House in 2024. it's not impossible but
we tried to warn people turning point
actions on the ground we were not going
to endorse trying to raise money the RNC
nowhere to be found M.I.A that's why we
tried to do everything we could to get
regime change done at the RNC they
wouldn't be bothered they were too busy
doing their things that they do which is
nothing but pay themselves and
take care of their DC consultants and
then Chicago not as if it
was in a going in a hopeful Direction
decided to elect an outright Marxist
model Marxist is going to become mayor
of Chicago okay he's not a Marxist but
let's focus in on the Supreme Court
piece of this the only way they can win
is cheating and overturning the will of
the voters he sang The Quiet part out
loud he is saying now now I'll give you
hit I know he doesn't mean to be saying
this but what he is in practice saying
is the way we were going to win in 2024
was by filing motions that would
hopefully get to the Wisconsin Supreme
Court and the Wisconsin Supreme Court
would decide to give us the electoral
votes now if you ask Charlie about it
he'll say no no no no I'm not saying
we're going to cheat what I mean is
Democrats will try to cheat
and then we will have to go to the
Supreme Court of Wisconsin in order to
get the rightful results which are that
Trump or whoever will be the winner but
who has a history of doing this stuff
remember you look at 2020. they spent
the entire summer saying Democrats are
going to try to cheat and we know they
actually tried to we know that they had
a number of these fraudulent elector
scams going in different states we know
that they filed endless motions to try
to circumvent the actual will of the
people
uh this is actually very good news for
Wisconsin where in Wisconsin you have
women worried about losing control over
their own medical care who now have a
better shot at retaining it thanks to
the change in the Wisconsin Supreme
Court and of course the fact that
Charlie Kirk's big concern is we were
relying on that court in order to try to
win in 2024 tells you everything you
need to know about who and what they
care about he's sang The Quiet part out
loud that Wisconsin result could end up
being really important speaking of cults
right-wing commentator Anna Perez says
she'd be willing to take a bullet for
Trump and that Trump would be willing to
take a bullet for her this is
interesting on a few different levels
let's take a listen to it something that
really kind of inspired me before I did
this show uh was hearing Ryan what Ryan
said in the episode that he did today
right before this he said I would take a
bullet for president Trump and when he
said that at first I was a little taken
aback I was like all right Ryan that's a
little that's a little much but then I
thought about it for a split second and
then I realized no it's not you know why
because president Trump would take a
bullet for me president Trump is taking
a bullet for me president Trump is
prepared to take a bullet for all of us
and of course that is not true so let's
talk about a couple different things
here first of all it's funny to me that
these Trump supporters still think Trump
cares about them it's it's so up
abundantly apparent now Beyond any
question that Trump does not like his
supporters Trump has spent his entire
life as a rich guy from New York City
trying to stay away from folks that are
like the vast majority of those who
support him that's first Trump would not
take a bullet for anyone remember when
Trump said he would have run into the
building where there was a shooter no he
would not so so they are wrongly
assessing that Trump cares about them
but this is a great reminder about
cult-like traits you've got your leader
who demands complete loyalty and
obedience from their followers Trump
fits that description perfectly during
the presidency since leaving office he
demands every follower must always
remain loyal above all else he'll use
fear he'll use intimidation to keep him
in line and when they go off script
Trump instantly abandons them another
sign of occult is using propaganda
techniques to manipulate your followers
and again Trump does it he lies all the
time to his followers and says don't
believe what you're hearing and seeing
simply believe what I tell you and if
anyone criticizes me you know they're
lying and they're trying to deceive you
and the followers buy it and they go wow
this person criticized Trump let's go
and attack that person it's blind
cult Behavior Cults also do the US
versus them thing if you're not part of
the group you're part of the enemy
you're either with us or against us and
this is something that is super common
with Trump supporters if you disagree
with them you're demonized you're fake
news news article adversarial to Trump
fake news
political view different than Trump's
Un-American Marxist communist and it's a
sort of extreme tribalism extreme
tribalism and it is very cult-like and
then the other thing I think is
important to mention
is that Cults often will require members
require it'll just happen over time to
kind of give up their own identities and
to conform to the beliefs and the
practices and sometimes even the
physical appearance and the slang and
the ideology the physical you know the
the clothing Etc of the cult and Trump
supporters have shown that as well and
it's not just literally the red Maga
hats it's the adopting these irrational
beliefs embracing conspiracy theories
simply because this is what the group
now believes rejecting science
threatening violence in defense of their
beliefs so all of the warning signs are
clear this is a cult Anna Perez embodies
that blind loyalty propaganda Us Versus
Them willingness to give up your own
identity and we need to Simply call it
out to prevent others from falling in I
don't know that I can save Anna Perez I
I really don't but maybe we can prevent
someone else from falling into this
insanity Alex Jones is turning on Trump
and Trump supporters and I have to tell
you this broken clocks you know the
entire thing
Alex Jones analysis of Trump's Tuesday
night rant at Mar-A-Lago
actually is quite accurately assessing
the reality of trump and his own
supporters I'll just play it for you
Alex Jones is making a lot of sense here
oh yeah okay other than this noise he's
making a lot of sense thank you oh
that's not the sound I want to hear
this is one of my big irritants with
high-level Trump supporters they're in
there drinking it's a big carnival they
love being near the president they love
the fancy beautiful architecture yeah
and they just it's like a beauty pageant
or something like they feel like they've
arrived I've seen it I've been around it
and there is just a delirium and the
same thing happened as rallies oh we're
Invincible oh we can't be stopped it was
just drove me crazy
sometimes there's two minutes of
applause
and and whooping and hollering and you
just it's like they're having fun this
is not fun
I've just been around the Trump people
and around Trump when there's people
around and everybody's like oh hi and I
can't believe they're there and oh it's
like they're in the cool kid club and
I've been saying that
for six years but he never did it
all right so I have to tell you Alex
Jones is completely correct there is a
delirium in the room at these events
like the one at Mar-A-Lago on Tuesday
the vibe at Mar-A-Lago we were watching
it for like an hour before Trump spoke
we could see what was going on
it was like you were there for something
positive and I know some of them are
trying to spin it into the indictment is
good because it means Trump is going to
win it might help him in the primary I
don't think it helps them with even a
single new vote in the general election
if he makes it that far but there is
again we just talked about cult-like
it's cult-like and Alex Jones knows
about cults he's tried to build one I
mean the Infowars audience is not
exactly clear thinking but he is
completely correct that it why is there
a party atmosphere at Mar-A-Lago he's
been accused of 34 felonies there are
more allegations coming now I know they
just write it off they say this is all
just bogus but there is a Detachment
from reality a delirium really is the is
the best word for it
that Alex Jones accurately points out
and I I almost think Trump can get
sentenced to prison and he would be
turning himself over to start his
sentence
and they would have a party and cheer
because somehow some cult leader would
tell them this is actually a good thing
and I'll tell you why it's bizarre to
see let's hope that it leads to their
own destruction electorally in 2024.
we've got a pact program today glad
you're here quick break and then it
continues
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show unlike much of
what you get on cable news actually does
depend on individuals who say I am going
to sign up for a membership we don't get
cable subscription fees like Fox News we
don't have huge oil conglomerates
advertising with us we actually depend
on small dollar contributions from
people who sign up at joinpakman.com you
can of course sign up using the coupon
code indicted we know what that means
and you can also sign up using the
coupon code indicated if you prefer
either one works and of course uh we
understand the meaning of each of these
coupon codes very very well all right
let's hear from some people in the
audience we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord it is an
extraordinary situation uh this week
historic in many different ways and I do
want to hear from people in the audience
let's start today with Jackson from
Sanford Jackson from Sanford welcome to
the pro program what's on your mind
today
Jackson from Sanford you're on once you
select your correct audio device we'll
be able to hear you
and Jackson from Sanford is gone let's
go to Dave from Northern California Dave
from Northern California welcome to the
program uh would love to hear what is on
your mind today
Dave from Northern California please
accept my invitation to join the
discussion
hi David hi
how are you today okay
um I was calling to talk about your plan
to try to reduce gun violence sure I
agree with you in principal I share the
same goals
but I come from the perspective of
knowing that there are
easily over a hundred million
semi-automatic Firearms most people have
at least two magazines I've met people
who have a hundred magazines that are
over the capacity limit that you've
talked about in the past I don't see how
any law that could be passed
would successfully rid the world
um of the country of those firearms and
I've got anecdotal cases
um for why I think any law would still
be defeatable with current technology
well so how do you suppose that that
would work it's it's not really I mean
I've already addressed that in the
formulation of my proposal which is
there is no one law that will solve the
problem but what we want to do given
that there's a second amendment and
given that there are hundreds of
millions of guns out there we want to
see can we reduce can we reduce and so
you're absolutely right I mean listen
part parts of the proposals are you
require licensing maybe some of the
people I'm sorry you require Insurance
some of the people who have a whole
bunch of firearms might say hey you know
what I don't want to pay as much in
insurance so I will choose to get rid of
some of these weapons you have a gun
buyback program for certain firearms
that doesn't mean anyone's forced to
give them back but you give an off ramp
to people so I agree I mean I don't know
that we disagree I'm on the same page as
you there given the circumstances and
where we are today there is no one law
that's going to solve the problem but
what I want to do is say is there
low-hanging fruit that does doesn't
violate the second amendment that we can
use to help and improve the problem
that's where I am
well so the reason that I find that
argument unconvincing uh is Illustrated
with an example from close to me uh last
week a gentleman was arrested in
possession of methamphetamine for sale
he was a convicted felon and he had a
gun on him that prompted uh a search of
his home where they located two more
Firearms one of which was a AR-15 that
was one of these ghost guns although
that phrase is really mocked within the
gun Community I think it's better to say
a built at home gun from a kit
um and this person was a convicted felon
in a state like California that has
restrictions against AR-15s this wasn't
compliant in any of the ways that the
laws in California and he made the gun
himself at home I've seen documentaries
that claim over 150 million blanks have
been sold for making these Firearms so
I'm just extremely pessimist that that
strategy can work
yeah and like I said you're you're sort
of proving my point which is of course
you're going to have stories like that
and you are right it's possible that my
10 ideas wouldn't have prevented this
guy in California from having built a
gun and I don't I don't purport to have
a solution to that so again I don't
think we're in disagreement I think
we're up against a real challenge here
but we can't say since it won't solve
that problem you just identified we
should do nothing that I can't get
behind
yeah and I understand that
um very much I guess what I'm trying to
do is is direct the conversation towards
Solutions I think have any chance
whatsoever and the political give me
give me one such solution I've got 40
people waiting but give me one such
solution we can think about and then I'm
gonna move on okay
well um that that's the problem is I
don't have one and I understand
completely what you're saying it's time
to move on um so thank you very much for
taking my call and um congratulations on
the birth of your child all right Dave
from Northern California great to hear
from you let's go to Amos from Kansas
Amos from Kansas City Welcome to the
program what's on your mind today hi
David I'm a long time listener long time
supporter of you and I'm happy to be on
here first time I've ever gotten on but
uh at first I had a question but I
wanted to answer one of your questions
that you asked a couple of weeks ago but
Lauren bobert loves to say those words
pleading the blood of Jesus yeah I was
born and raised Apostolic Pentecostal so
I could tell you what that means please
what does it mean
it's kind of a legal term
but in the way that like Jesus died for
you because and that blood that he's
built was a covenant between God and man
and so when things go wrong we plead the
blood of the Covenant
and who do you plead who do you plead to
God himself God the father because the
Covenant is Jesus Christ's blood and
he's that's and yeah that's the best way
I can explain it but that's how it's
explained to me it growing up and what
are you pleading for
it depends on the situation like I guess
foreign situation it would be pleading
the blood out for you know making Trump
president or something like that so if I
understand correctly you would plead the
blood of Jesus to God in order to
achieve something that you want yes
pretty much okay all right very good I
understand that that's just my
explanation for it but anyway uh my
question for you has to deal with I I'm
a big follower of a guy named Hemet
Metta and he did a uh uh pull and he's
like you he gets these a plus rated
polls and stuff but he did it on the the
religions of the world that are best
seen most positively and most negatively
okay and I wanted to to know your
opinion on this because it according to
the poll Mormons are the most are the
least
positively viewed religion however even
though it doesn't seem like it based
upon the I don't know the loudness of
the minorities
it Jews are the most positively seen
according to his pose yeah so so let's
let's be clear the poll you're referring
to is a Pew Research Center poll so I
think it's important when we say his
poll I follow Hemet on on Twitter it's a
Pew Research Center poll so quite uh
quite quite reputable
um so the uh this is only among
Americans I think it's important to
mention that's one thing this these are
not Global views about these different
religions and you're absolutely right
among Americans
Jews followed by uh let's well see it's
kind of complicated because of how this
is ranked Jews almost perfectly followed
by Catholics then Mainline Protestants
then Evangelical Christians then
atheists Muslims and Mormons in that
order are seen as most favorable to sort
of like least favorable
um the difficulty about that poll is
it's all kind of low numbers like the
difference between the least favorable
which is Mormons and Jews which is the
most favorable is only 20 points it's 15
to 35. so I I have a couple different
thoughts on this number one
um the U.S
has a a different sort of perspective on
a lot of these religions than the world
so like I think that Mormonism might be
seen differently in other parts of the
world where the like the population of
Mormons is very different I mean it's a
very interesting poll I don't really
know what to make of it I do think that
when it comes to Jews some of the
favorable is probably based in
anti-semitic tropes like people who are
like oh yeah Jews control some great
Industries so like I see them favorably
in that way but it doesn't necessarily
mean that like you necessarily think
Jews are good people or whatever you
know what I'm saying right right but it
is a very interesting poll yeah I I you
know the other thing about it is the
vast majority of respondents have no
opinion about most of those religions
like 60 of the respondents said I don't
have any I don't know enough about Jews
to say one way or the other
well if if it's any consolation I view
all all Jews to be the you know my my uh
mother's side of the family is a lot of
there's a lot of that is Jewish okay but
anyway thank you very much all right
yeah very interesting Paul thanks for
bringing it up I do appreciate that
let's go next to Dean from Dallas Dean
from Dallas welcome to the David Pacman
show what's on your mind today
hey David
um I called in a couple times I don't
know if you remember me uh but I wanted
to ask a couple questions you know there
are these buzzwords which are often
associated with like a political party
like when you hear Patriot or Freedom
you think of the right wing or Maga why
doesn't the left
attempt to take the positive ones back
why do we concede those terms that can
obviously apply to the party in big ways
we've talked about this before I think
it's actually a great idea like when we
talk about what it means to be patriotic
there's a very cartoonish version on the
right and for me you know patriotism
would be hey you know what I take pride
in my country making sure no one is
starving that no one is homeless it's
like that would be a new form of
patriotism that I think would be much
more interesting and inspiring and
positive I can't answer the question why
have Democrats or the left not taken
back these terms there's a bunch of
writing about this George lakehoff has
talked about Republicans winning the
framing War you know I I unfortunately
Dean I Can't Tell You Why Democrats or
the left haven't done it but you're
absolutely right in diagnosing that a
lot of these terms have been kind of
perverted and certainly used exclusively
by the right to have narrow meanings and
the left should try to take them back
but I don't really know what the first
step would be
yeah and then I had a second question if
you don't mind sure do you have any
thoughts on uh cultural assimilation do
you think it's more positive or negative
or does it make us stronger as a country
or what are your opinions on it well I
think that when people talk about
cultural assimilation usually it's often
used to draw a very specific political
perspective out of people and my view on
cultural assimilation is I think one of
the things that makes the United States
great is that you do have all of these
different cultures that when things are
going well can can sort of coexist and I
think it's actually a great thing and
also I recognize that there are
difficulties that surface if you have
different types of division like when
people talk about hey this is America we
speak English here yeah listen I mean in
a practical sense
in order to best communicate it's good
to have a shared language so I agree
with the idea that if someone comes to
the United States and lives in the
United States for 30 years and speaks no
English that's going to be an impediment
both for them and for the rest of
society to relate I also think it's a
great thing
to understand and respect and embrace
different cultures and that includes
different languages and bilingualism and
all of these different things so the the
problem you know to say is cultural
assimilation good or bad uh to some
degree if we're all going to live
together we need to have some shared
touch points and language respect for
different religions respect for
different countries of Origins all of
these different things are really
important but to objectively just say
cultural assimilation is good or bad
gets us into the kind of black and white
thinking that often gets us nowhere
yeah it kind of seems like our country
as a whole is just it's a constant
battle since we're so split of like what
the new American dream or the American
way of living is like it used to be like
own a house you know have kids married
get and get a good job go to college and
all those things you know like it's kind
of Shifting you know people like
right-wing conservative players are
saying you know college is where you go
to get woke don't go to college or
whatever
it's
it's uh and you know where people are
making more social protests it's like
during like the Pledge of Allegiance or
you know uh the singing of The
Star-Spangled Banner or people not
standing you know it's kind of yeah and
to be clear for me the Pledge of
Allegiance is just so silly I don't even
consider it when I think about an issue
like cultural assimilation it's just
nonsense to me okay all right Dean from
Dallas appreciate the call Great
questions thank you
all right there it goes Dean from Dallas
very very powerful topics I must say
let's go to Dan from Illinois Dan from
Illinois welcome to the David pakman
show what's on your mind today
hi David can you hear me yes I can
oh I'm so glad you picked me um before I
get to my question I wanted to
congratulate you on having such an
excellent show
um I've been a viewer for a couple years
now and I think the reason why I've
become a daily viewer of yours is
because the quality of what you do uh
and the degree to wish you think through
and present things is uh so above and
beyond what is out there wow well I
appreciate that yes and specifically if
I could uh if I could if I could say I
think the thing that's most valuable to
me is when you do very specific
breakdowns that that delve into issues
very deeply a lot of what's out there in
the media especially corporate media it
doesn't it doesn't really help people
understand complex issues and I love
what you do
so well I appreciate that very much Dan
thank you
absolutely encourage you to continue on
that and so that that being said the
question that I have is um about
something that you and I agree on okay
that you that you've talked about
I haven't heard you go more in depth and
so you've talked about the importance of
media literacy yes
um and I would love to hear your
thoughts on I guess both ways like if
you could wave a magic wand how would
you approach media literacy but also
maybe like what would fit into reality
because
um I mean I could speak to them where
I'll I'll let you answer well as I've
said before I think that really you
really want to be teaching media
literacy as young as people start
consuming media now how do you teach a
two-year-old who watches cartoons media
literacy well you know you start to
distinguish commercials from the
programming I think right I mean you
start very simple but as a matter of
school curriculum
certainly by sixth grade there should be
just it should be standard that we're
teaching media literacy understanding
the difference between news and opinion
understanding the impact of you know
advertisers product placement just
because you saw something on TV or on
the Internet does it mean it's true
what's the different all of this basic
stuff the earlier you arm people with
tools needed the less that they're ever
going to fall for Fox News or Newsmax
and it's sort of like it's sort of like
a vaccine against disinformation so I
would like to see it just be a standard
part of school curriculum starting
probably I used to say seventh grade now
I'm probably more at like sixth grade
maybe even fifth
I I couldn't agree more
um I think that this is actually a core
of what is causing many many issues uh
because it's so easy for anyone to say
anything yes
um and just understanding sort of the
psychology of media how it affects
people there's uh a lot of people using
it in you know nefarious ways
self-serving ways and uh for for my
vantage point I sort of feeling like I'm
watching things we're sort of sliding
off of a cliff with 100 uh without that
sense of how are we going to come back
from this are do you have any voices or
books or resources that you've looked to
in terms of uh people who are kind of
have expertise in that that has informed
your sense of like how that could
actually be done or how we could
actually look to do that not from a
policy standpoint you know on my book
recommendation list on my website I have
tons of books about thinking that I
recommend but none of them are policy
oriented in that way uh but I'll look
around and see if there are any
awesome well thank you so much that
answers uh what I wanted to talk to you
about so all right Dan from Illinois
very much appreciate the call we're
going to take more calls but let's take
a very quick break and then we'll be
back if you're holding on to talk to me
don't hang up because we're going right
back to the phones
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's
continue speaking to people from the
audience we take calls on the Friday
show via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord I want to go next to Freddy from
Monterey Freddie from Monterey welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
what can I do for you
Freddy from Monterey
can you hear me yes I can
hey um thanks for taking my call uh it's
a question um
here in California and I am going in two
weeks to Wisconsin to a family wedding
and I know a very important election
just happened I believe that was today
so earlier this week and Tuesday on
Tuesday there was a liberal Supreme
Court Justice elected to the Wisconsin
Supreme Court and this makes the court a
liberal court for the first time in 15
years major implications for abortion
rights gerrymandering maybe even the
2024 election
right which is great yeah I was looking
at that the whole gerrymandering thing
and um absolutely insane how the
Republicans can do that
um but I was just wondering
you know I'm going there and I'm
realizing that a lot of the family uh
in-laws family that I'm gonna be around
probably don't have the same views as me
and somebody hadn't made a joke about us
coming from California and they were
going to let us know this and this and
this so I was just I know you like to
you have a little pointers on
um
how I should go about
what I say you know and like try not to
get in the arguments you know it's like
my wife's family and stuff I I don't
well here are my suggestions I actually
wrote a guide about this and if you go
to davidpackman.com guide uh some people
call it a white paper some call it a
guide this is free it's like 10 pages
it's called building arguments without
Burning Bridges and it'll give you a lot
of ideas and fundamentally the decision
you have to make is
what sort of relationship do you want to
have with the folks you're visiting and
that will kind of inform how
confrontational or adversarial you want
to be but yeah free guide available on
that topic davidpackman.com guide
oh great that's cool okay yeah just I
mean I'm pretty excited about you know
the results that happened over there and
I'm like oh yeah I'm going to Wisconsin
this is great but then I'm like oh
should I show how excited I am you know
it's like I gotta just play it by ear I
guess I think that's the smartest thing
all right cool well that's about it
thank you all right thanks Freddie
Freddie's got a lot going on there and
headed to Wisconsin very soon which I'm
sure will be a very very powerful trip
let's go to Bert from New Jersey Bert
from New Jersey welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hey David you hear me okay yeah
okay awesome
I call in a lot about economic issues so
I promise I'll call them about other
things but a couple more to get off my
chest sure
um you hear a compromise a lot from the
right about Trump where they'll say like
you know I don't like him as a person
but I don't disagree with his policies
right right I think a lot of that comes
from people on the left tend to
criticize him a little too much I think
that filters out the criticism it
doesn't make its way to his policies
enough right and I'll give you an
example of one that I think you agree
with me on
um for example like the PPP loan policy
right yes we can now look back at that
and we can say that was just an abysmal
terrible policy
um you know you could say is the
greatest form of Socialism ever
implemented we're just shoveling money
at people like crazy well hold on a
second so let's let's see if we can
break that down a little bit Bert So
when you say we were shoveling are you
talking specifically about the business
PPP aspect or are you talking about the
covid stimulus more broadly where money
was just sent to people
yes good question let me clarify I'm
talking about the business side of
things okay the problem for me for the
PPP program was not that you were just
giving businesses money the problem for
me was that there wasn't enough
oversight there was tons of Fraud and it
ended up being a horrible slush fund
that was my problem with it
right but I think the policy around it
was garbage and here's why
um I don't know if you took the PPP
loans for your business or not I'm uh
technology startup and uh it was my job
to go out and administer that PPP loan
yeah so I'd find the paperwork and all
the things I was shocked at how little
there was to qualify all you had to do
is check a box that says yes my business
has been negatively affected by covid
unless you're in the business of selling
toilet paper or making coffee filters
who's who's not going to check that box
right yeah and listen I decided not to
take the money I later learned that
there were other people in my cohort who
who did take some of that money it is
true that the IRS is heavily focusing on
now auditing uh uh people who
fraudulently took money I feel fine I
mean yeah listen I get it there was
government money out there for the
taking I don't regret not taking it I
mean we everybody was home watching
shows we had a really great year that
year like it would have just been wrong
for me to take it but your point is
absolutely correct it was too easy to
get that money
right and and you know Tom Brady got a
million dollar loan like why does why
does government to bail Tom Brady's
company out right that's just one
example in my circle the common uh uh
talk about was hey this is free money go
out and get it right and you need to
prove you needed it so my question is
now that we can look back at this why is
it sounds like I'm criticized on the
right I'm actually more criticized than
the left like why isn't this being
talked about this is a terrible policy
that you know caused inflation I can go
and listen to all the things that happen
here why isn't this being brought up
well I think the left has to criticize
both Trump policy and Trump sort of like
tone and this the non-policy stuff I
think for a lot of people the reality is
Bert because of attention spans and so
many other different factors it's much
easier to remind people about you know
Trump believed everything Putin told
them and he believed everything Kim
Jong-un told him and he drew on a marker
with a he drew with a marker uh on the
hurricane map and he wasn't sure why we
couldn't nuke Europe and a lot of that
stuff is much easier to come communicate
quickly then the policy stuff but I
agree with you completely I think the
other aspect on Trump and policy is he
also didn't do that much because so many
of the things he said he was going to do
obviously weren't going to happen so for
example the big criticism on Trump on
the israeli-palestinian conflict is he
promised to solve it within a year and
they didn't and the one thing he did
moving the air the uh Embassy to
Jerusalem was actually counterproductive
right but on a lot of these things Trump
didn't actually do anything
right right now absolutely the other
thing I think about too is like what if
the roles reversed here what if this was
Obama right what would the right be
saying about this this would be like Ben
gonzi Benghazi 2.0 there'd be committees
there'd be investigations why would you
let this taxpayer money go to fraud
right none of that seems to be happening
oh they'd be demanding that Obama be put
in prison if he had overseen PPP there's
no doubt about that Bert good points and
well made I appreciate it
thank you David all right Bert from New
Jersey excellent excellent stuff let's
go next why don't we go to Peter from
Allentown Peter from Allentown welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
I have a just kind of a quick question
yes
do you think the United States will ever
fully adopt the metric system
you know the best reason I read about
why the U.S will not adopt the metric
system is a combination of having to
re-educate everyone and the cost of all
the signs having to make all new signs
that it would just that that it's sort
of like it's a path dependent Monopoly
sort of situation that we're on where
we're so far in that it's always like
well it really doesn't make sense to do
it and then you're further in and then
you can say wow now it really doesn't
make sense to do it so now I don't know
I would love for the US to adopt the
metric system I really don't see it
happening
I mean I mean there was a push I
remember back when I was in elementary
school in the 70s there was this big
push they had little little cartoon
little songs kind of like Schoolhouse
Rock but with the metric system yeah and
there was a rule real you know honest
push but it just there's some I don't
know what it is about the American
psyche or culture that there's such a
resistance with it they probably think
it's kind of like you know like it's 50
European yeah those Europeans with
everything based on tens obviously we're
gonna have you know a 5 280 foot mile
and a 12 inch foot yeah I mean it's it
is crazy no I I agree I think there is
that is a factor yeah those CIS
Europeans with their metric system of
course it's like almost the entire
planet
all right well thanks Amy that's all I
wanted to thank you all right Peter from
Allentown thank you very much appreciate
the call why don't we go next to oh I
don't know it's just it's the the phone
lines are just packed folks packed let's
go to Eric from Philly Eric from Philly
welcome to the program what's going on
and you gotta unmute yourself there you
go
sorry about that
um thank you very much I knew you were
going to pick me as soon as I went
through the drive-thru
um okay quick question for you please do
you think Republicans are going with the
arming teachers
um argument because they think it's a go
nowhere issue because I really don't
believe Society is going to be okay with
army I actually I don't know I mean I
think that there are private schools
that there might even be some private
schools that have done it and maybe some
that will but I do think you're right
that as a matter of public schools
teachers aren't going to be armed
anytime soon and part of what
Republicans need is anytime somebody
like me proposes you know 10 different
things we could do about gun safety they
say no to all of them and some of those
Republicans and right-wingers and gun
people would like to at least be able to
pretend that they're offering something
as opposed to just saying no and so I
think part of what you're suspecting is
correct which is they go well let's arm
teachers and let's lock the doors or
whatever just so they can say we're not
saying do nothing here's what we want to
do and of course they're never really
going to have to legislate it because
Public Schools I I would never say never
Eric because never is a long time but at
any time soon we are not going to see
teachers armed at Public Schools
all right thanks for answering my
question I appreciate it
all right Eric from Philly thank you
very much great to hear from you why
don't we go next to Caesar from Florida
Caesar from Florida Welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
Caesar please
Caesar I'm guessing you have the wrong
audio device selected
no boy
that's really too bad let's try Josiah
from North Carolina Josiah welcome to
the program what's going on DPAC how are
you doing well
so obviously big news from Wisconsin
um as you heard that Republicans in
Wisconsin are already at least a few of
them talking about impeaching Justice
pro to say which
uh I did not hear that for what reason
uh well I mean uh right now they're just
kind of forecasting it they would come
up with grounds that she's not going to
uh not going to uh abide by her oath
she's not going to support Wisconsin law
right and the the idea is just you know
throw anything at her that sticks would
you be surprised if they do that if they
actually impeach her or if they try to
try to oh uh no it would not surprise me
but you know oftentimes it's sort of
like Marjorie Taylor green has tried to
impeach Joe Biden but it doesn't even
like get started so you know the word
try is doing a lot of heavy work there
you know what I mean
the the bulk of my question concerns
actually my state North Carolina I don't
know if you heard this but one of our
state representatives her name is Trisha
cotham just this morning she formally
announced that she was switching from
the Democratic party to the Republican
Party even though she ran as a democrat
in November and was just sworn in in
January the first my first question is
do you consider this fraudulent
so I think the problem with fraudulent
or unethical is can you prove that this
was her intent at the time obviously
you're allowed to switch party but if
there was uh I I think in order to
demonstrate that it's fraudulent you
would have to demonstrate that this was
part of a plan all the way from the
beginning I don't know whether you can
demonstrate that or not if you could I
think it would certainly be fraudulent
that's fair that's fair and certainly I
agree to like a legal scrutiny I I would
not I would not make the case that uh
there's a compelling case to be made
that you could prove it to a legal
satisfaction but yeah I guess she you
know she ran as a progressive Democrat
in Mecklenburg County which is a really
blue District of North Carolina it's
just right out so it's part of Charlotte
yeah and it seems to me pretty sketched
that in three months she's switching
parties switching platforms and there's
no uh run off or recall like provision
there would you support in the event
that um a politician switches parties
and switches platforms and things like
that that it triggers some sort of
recall or runoff provision that's really
tough I I would I'm open to voters
deciding whether they want a recall I
don't know about automatically doing it
and here's the difficulty people do
change positions during the time that
they're in office so then you would have
to say well if you change positions
enough or if you change party my view is
you the voters should be able to gather
signatures if they want to recall
someone but It ultimately has to be up
to the voters I'm not going to say
anytime you change party you should be
immediately there should be a recall
election that seems like too much but
you should be subject to a recall
yeah I guess it's it's kind of it's the
reason I'm so salty about it is because
her doing so has given Republicans in
North Carolina a veto proof majority we
were one seat away from it and Governor
Cooper was kind of you know he's a
Democrat he was getting by by the skin
of his teeth and now that she switched
parties it's a it's a veto proof
majority it's ugly it's ugly no doubt I
understand that and and I mean listen
the voters can consider that in
determining whether they would want to
have a recall election
no yeah I agree as far as I know I don't
think that it even allows like a recall
election I agree that you're probably
right that an auto recall is probably
too cumbersome but there at least should
be a provision that if enough of her
constituents like I think in the event
of um George Santos right the guy the
serial liar at a North Carolina 80 out
of New York New York New York oh yeah
yeah sorry I'm a North Carolina brand at
the moment but yeah New York 80 of his
constituents want him to resign right
and as far as I know there's no recall
provision there like even if enough of
his constituents demand his resignation
he's he's allowed to serve the remainder
of his terms yeah not every place has
recall Provisions but very very
interesting situation there in North
Carolina I appreciate you telling us
about it I appreciate that David have a
good one all right there goes Josiah and
that'll do it for calls today we'll take
a quick break and then get to your
emails and your tweets and your comments
and the entire thing
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
okay let's do Friday feedback and uh
it's I know many of you wrote to me and
said David what is Friday feedback going
to be like this week after what happened
last week and going through the hate mob
that came after you well I I'm not going
to make this all negative there were
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of disgusting hate messages
including many anti-Semitic but what I
do want to tell you
is that there is a movement that is
insisting there were no such hate
messages there were no anti-semitic
messages or anything and you can
sometimes see them quite literally next
to anti-semitic messages for example
user Shane used the anti-semitic meme 6
million which of course relates to the
Six Million Jews killed in the Holocaust
and they love to reference like should
have been more or whatever right 6
million so this is another one of these
anti-semitic messages next to a message
that says there's not a hate mob after
you
there are just thousands of individual
people that heard your comments and
found them disgusting really and why
does that then necessitate making
horrible comments about the Holocaust
it's sort of difficult to understand but
many other fascinating messages on the
substance
of preventing mass shootings and
reducing gun violence we got a great
comment on YouTube which reads David as
a veteran of law enforcement myself and
gun owning individual while also being a
Christian father of two
don't let Republicans drag you down the
rabbit hole they intend you to do so
when engaging you your list of 10 is
quite honestly very good these are ten
policies to reduce gun violence I laid
out what I would add is specifically a
sliding scale fee and structure that
low-income Americans do not get
financially discriminated against when
following the list of ten ah so this
might be
the training
scales for in the cost of training and
Licensing scales for income I I think I
get the idea and a very interesting idea
for sure
Henman left the message and says David
I'm a rock solid Centrist with not much
of an appreciation for left or right but
you are one of the very few leftist
commentators I watch consistently
because of your balanced calm collected
demeanor when tackling subjects hold
fast against the fascist hordes of
Republicans and their extended members
we're behind you all the way to defend
your free speech not right wing Define
free speech I mean freedom of speech in
the traditional sense of the word before
it was hijacked by the right all the
best with much love for the UK thank you
and lots of Brits by the way weighing in
recently which I very very much
appreciate
sharielle said by going after you they
moved the Target off of them for doing
absolutely nothing to stop this horrible
epidemic that only happens in our
country bless you David I'm so sorry
you're having to go through this yeah
you know uh there must not be anything
we can do to stop the scourge of gun
violence
say people in the only country where
this is regularly happening are we
really that willing to give up without
trying almost anything it's really
pathetic on the issue of thoughts and
prayers
uh very interesting comment the
Congressional this is Riley the
Congressional chaplain said it was time
for more than thoughts and prayers
does he get threatened you're in the
right David yeah and in fact you know
what's been really interesting since the
blow up last week is that all sorts of
other the prayers Aren't Enough did they
not pray correctly or hard enough sort
of stuff dozens at least of relatively
prominent people made similar statements
there was one in the Boston Globe and
others
none of them generated any controversy
any controversy okay then we're moving
on to some other issues Jason commented
on Facebook David underwear Pac-Man I
don't even know what that means instead
of reviewing polls maybe you should look
at the actual statistics of illegal
immigrants crossing the border why do
they always put the wrong border border
like a boarding house rather than the
U.S Mexico border Jason says it's in the
millions and the highest ever because of
Biden's policies how can you even try to
defend this topic there is no border
again wrong border b-o-a-r-d-e-r but
merely a fading Line in the Sand
remember a couple things on that number
one
they are stopping people from coming in
oh the border is clearly open because of
all the people that border patrol is
stopping
wait so
it must be closed then because they're
stopping people that's number one number
two we know a lot about the surge of
attempts under Joe Biden it started to
increase under Trump as covid waned
Mobility resumed and people started
again trying to come over the Border in
greater numbers they act like we don't
know that they're a simple explanations
for most of these things let's now go to
the subreddit El Deus t
wrote Marjorie Taylor Greene says we
need more good guys with guns I think
she's right but how do you become a good
guy with a gun introducing the good guy
with a gun certificate pass the mental
assessment
pass the background check pass the gun
safety course congratulations you're now
a certified good guy with a gun now of
course I would go further
you get yourself the required the the
liability insurance that should be
required in order to have firearms you
are regularly retested and undergo uh
regular psych evals
you were limited in terms of high
capacity magazines based on your age
it's quite an extensive list
um but certainly we are nowhere near
that at this point in time continuing to
talk about firearms
this is this is an interesting message
question from a non-american
why are Americans so obsessed with guns
why do you need them and why are some of
you against restrictions some people
don't even acknowledge the problem I
mean what do you expect there have been
more mass shootings than days in 2023 so
what can be done
armed teachers as was proposed blame
things that have nothing to do with it
trans people video games porn Etc
or ban on some kind of weapons like
assault weapons yeah this you know this
person got downvoted down into a a hole
in the ground but they're absolutely
right and it's it's interesting there
are right-wing pro-gun people
who bristle at the idea that
Europeans might tell us what to do with
guns well we should look at it a
different way we should say people from
countries that don't have this epidemic
of gun violence are shocked and
horrified by what's happening in the
United States maybe we should consider
whether they have something to offer and
this is part of the problem you know as
when I was on the pbd program Patrick
Bett David's podcast and I explained
under Trump Global opinion of the U.S
and of the presidency was in the toilet
and
the response when they can no longer
deny the facts is to say why do we care
what other countries think of us if
other countries don't like us if other
countries are scared of us that means
we're doing the best possible thing we
can for Americans and of course that's
obviously not the case insofar as we
live in a globalized world we're not
this isolated country we're not an
island economically and and literally
we're not an island
we actually do depend on other countries
for so many things and so this idea of
what do we care what they think it's
predominantly an idea on the right and
it's extraordinarily short-sighted
um and unfortunately that's the issue
right oh my god look someone someone
from a country that has no gun violence
has the audacity to say what the hell is
wrong with you people in the U.S yeah
that should really make you think oh wow
you mean this is optional it doesn't
have to be like this
give me a break guys all right and then
more um superficially there was a poll
done on our subreddit what's your
favorite nickname for Ron DeSantis the
options were Rhonda sanctimonious tiny D
meatball Ron Gay Ron which I don't even
understand deep State Ron or something
else
overwhelmingly our Reddit audience
prefers meatball Ron as the name for
Rhonda Sanders I have to tell you I
don't really love it
I don't really love it and I know that
Rhonda sanctimonious is a problem
because many
um Republicans wouldn't know how to
spell sanctimonious nor what it means so
that one's problematic I still like
wrong death santis wrong death scientist
but it's a little tough to say
uh open to ideas this guy may not even
end up running so let's wait and see
before we subject him to a permanent
nickname all right keep those messages
coming you can email info
davidpackman.com you might post to the
subreddit and it could end up on Friday
feedback you might make a comment on
YouTube or send a tweet or God forbid
make a Facebook comment any of these
things could end up with you in Friday
feedback we have a tremendous bonus show
for you today I will be away the next
few days and be back with you next
Friday we will have a mix of guest hosts
including producer Pat
and others I think people will like it
if you hate all of the guest hosts
you'll be furious if you like one of the
guest hosts hopefully there will be a
little something for everyone next week
alright everybody so I'll see you then
on to the bonus show onward and upward
foreign